kevin o'leary the world famous investor
and star of abc shark tank was recently
asked in an interview about sovereign
wealth funds now these funds they are
the funds of entire countries and many
times they have billions if not hundreds
of billions of dollars in them and what
he said was absolutely shocking these
funds they want bitcoin one to three
percent and 99 of them only want bitcoin
here's kevin's comments from this
interview when i talk to sovereign
wealth i don't care if it's norway or
the uae or saudi
they want bitcoin they have not got to
the analysis that we've just gone
through they want the proxy uh of
bitcoin uh they want that volatility i
think
i think for financial services i agree
that eth the gas fees are a joke that's
the problem
this will help solve for it but if that
becomes the default uh platform for
other digital assets that will help but
in the immediate term
the demand is for one to three percent
of a portfolio a standard these these
these sovereign wealth portfolios look
like this no more than twenty percent in
one sector no more than five percent any
one name so you're never going to find
you know boeing or bank of america more
than five percent and 900 billion dollar
fund all the indexers know that it's a
really standard format
when you ask them if you could buy a
digital asset which one would it be and
what allocation it's about 50 basis
points on the low end up to 300 basis
points on the high end and 99 of the
time they say bitcoin that's all they
know now what's fascinating about this
is that sovereign wealth funds have
largely sat out from the crypto market
but if they start to come in not only do
they have hundreds of billions if not
trillions of dollars that they
collectively can deploy into the market
but they also tend to be very long-term
oriented and so if we see these large
asset allocators come into the market
and begin to actually hold on to
something like bitcoin that likely would
be a very bullish sign and provide for a
tailwind for the asset now what is
holding these exact investors back kevin
o'leary went on to explain that
regulatory clarity is a key missing
piece here's kevin explaining that piece
of the conversation it's going to take a
while for that demand to come and i
think it would be number two and they
certainly like usdc and they love solana
and paulie you go down the list based on
market cap i get it but right now if we
had policy on bitcoin
i swear to you the price of the price
would be 60 000 in two weeks now of
course it's important to understand who
these investors are and what's holding
them back but my general view is that
the regulatory stuff will sort itself
out we're seeing lots of regulatory
scrutiny due to various issues in the
crypto market but bitcoin continues to
be the one asset every regulator around
the world agrees on bitcoin is not a
security bitcoin is something that any
institutional investor can put into
their portfolio and it appears that the
sovereign wealth funds are warming up to
that idea and they likely are going to
start allocating very large dollars to
the asset
now of course these things take time and
it doesn't mean that bitcoin is just
going to rip upwards in price
immediately but what it does mean is
that if you're a long-term investor and
there is a finite supply asset like
bitcoin and there is increasing demand
over time if you look out 5 10 15 20
years that tends to be a trend that
you're going to want to pay attention to
hey you did you like this video great
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time